he's jason jackson miami heat talk about
the heat
tv host courtside reporter hosts
siriusxm nba radio and he joins us on
the program
well you saw that one coming last night
didn't you
[Laughter]
i tried to i try to lead heat nation dan
i don't
i don't try to you know prescribe to
um even though president uh
pat riley from the miami heat has those
two phases of just winning
and misery i try to be that bridge in
between
called hope okay all right you got a
chance to see tyler hero
all season long and i always say when
somebody says how would you describe him
i said he's not afraid
but you know the evolution or the
maturity or whatever it is i mean he's
20 years of age
you're not doing these things in the
playoffs at 20 years of age
why is tyler hero doing this uh he's the
son of a coach
and i think that stuff is real it's part
of his dna
to understand fully that first of all
it's work
like if you're going to get you've been
blessed you're tall
uh you you have an acumen for putting
the ball in the basket
uh you had no problem disappointing a
whole state
uh leaving wisconsin to go play at
kentucky uh
and when you play at kentucky you're
playing uh
in some some serious serious uh
basketball locations particularly
your home arena by the way with that big
blue nation who uh will love you
and will turn on you as you know full
will in an instant
so i think that one year helps and then
that space helps
because not only are you playing with
some of the best players in the country
you're playing with some of the best
alumni in the universe
and players came back obviously
that summer as he's coming to school
throughout the year
the summer after and now it's been a
year since training camp dance
ridiculous a year ago
next week i was dragging my behind up
and down interstate 95 to west palm
beach
just to get to know this kid but but
i'll briefly tell you this story
about seeing him the very first time i
think i told you the last time we were
together that
uh i do these charity events for
calipari they're in the bahamas
heroes in there getting busy like you're
seeing right now against
grown men now listen the national team
in the bahamas all right is is it's not
the dream team okay but those are grown
men
all right so i'm a little too grown i
believe there was a 35 year old cat out
there
getting busy but there was just i
remember calling my sons who follow all
the
young high school players across the
country going and i did like everybody
else said
there's this guy hannah i don't know
who's out here
who's out here jumping out of the gym
first of all so there's a part of his
game we still haven't seen
so you thought he was from another
country you gave him
well i've been in miami for so long
gotta roll your arms man
i was like i'm the only guy who will
ever be on your show that's
on peacock with peacocks out actually on
the street
well it's a beautiful existence down
here uh but yeah i
from the beginning you just see kind of
this and it matches his head coach by
the way
even up 30 down 30
hit one of 20 hit 19 of 20
a calmness and evenness and a
willingness stand
to take instruction not thinking because
you're doing so well as a young player
that you don't know anything and jimmy
butler from day one
uh woke his behind up at three in the
morning for workouts
created what is called tyler tuesday not
not as awesome as the catch phrase i'll
be stealing
about not just being a sub he's a hero
i usually go to mariah for that one and
a hero came along
oh you always had a soft spot in your
heart for mariah didn't you oh it hasn't
changed
no i don't care it's been dan you're
only human
30 years of a love affair through tommy
montola
she looks at me wrong one time one time
all right so i'm on the heat bandwagon
in fact i text you
i don't know when a couple days ago and
i said my heat
so how good is this team
let's say they get to the finals let's
say it's against
the lakers can they hold can they hold
their own with the lakers
given the makeup of who they are what
they have and going against
what the lakers have as long as it
doesn't trend the way it did in the two
regular season meetings
that would that would have to change but
everything with this team has changed
since then though the world has changed
um
it would uh listen needless to say i've
projected my brain a little bit
again you keep putting me in these
tenuous spots i have been a wonderful
uh miami heat employee for nearly 17
years because i don't talk like this in
public
dance but uh for you for you anything
um it comes down to a very simple thing
with the miami heat uh are you gonna
defend
like no one ever defends unlike game
three when
that that 60-point debacle in the paint
uh that they uh
could not stop like i'm not even saying
the heat defense was poor
just boston decided what they were gonna
do and got there and obviously
uh the adjustment you see the results of
that uh but but with
with the lakers man and and and god
bless the nuggets man for
not caring right but those two
you just don't have anything for those
two so you hope that you at least are
matching
uh a.d and lebron hopefully they're not
having those
all nba first team uh nights hopefully
lebron's not mad
about the voting process uh by the way
bring team broadcasters back in i think
that's where lebron should go
bring the team broadcasters back into
the voting that man's mvp
um would you have given him mvp
lebron yeah but again how could you be
wrong
how could you be wrong voting him mvp if
you chose to
simply because of the word value where
was that team
when he was injured down the stretch for
the first time in his career
and where was that team when he was on
the floor the majority of knights
it's just it's a really simple thing and
he's right for so long and you
and i have voted in this spot best team
best player that's that's
where i start as a voter that's and
that's not an
indictment against giannis at all i mean
we don't get a criteria when we get that
ballot with five slots
i don't think it was a problem either
way if you voted lebron one or two
i'm with lebron in the sense that the 16
first place vote seems
a little light it's like when you give
somebody a 20
and they give you two dollars back
you're like yo wait a minute that's not
the change
that's not i didn't purchase something
for 18 that's not how it works around
here
i'm gonna guess miami heat fans do they
want lebron
i think deep down they do knowing full
well that that's
you know a a lunch box a hard hat with a
light
and a thermos and and hoping to
to the almighty that you can get that
thing to seven games and and then see
what happens
uh listen if we're being super candid
and that's what you brought me on here
to do
uh the heater two years ahead of
schedule even though
jimmy has been telling this story about
winning
and winning the championship uh for a
year now
so if you if you just listen to jimmy
and you buy his 20
coffees uh you're you're set
yeah you start to look at these teams
these younger teams or younger players
and i think they've
the bubble has helped them i i think the
bubble is not good for older players
but for these younger guys who are 20 21
22
they don't have families you know okay
so you're
being you know put up in a hotel and all
you're doing is playing ball
and that's it no crowds you know there's
no
home court advantage you know you're not
going to
the boston garden to play and put up 37
points
and i i think it's been a real benefit
for some of these teams
i don't think denver comes back from
those 3-1 deficits
if they're actually going on the road to
these places i don't think they beat the
clippers
down three or you know down 3-1 but in
the bubble
it just neutralizes everybody your
thoughts
before this all started on on the campus
in orlando
what would prevail over talent like if
you just had
the better team what was going to win
and on a neutral floor it's if you can
get momentum swinging in your direction
what stops that i mean it's just nothing
so if you are
the the inferior seed and you can just
get
a couple things rolling then
you can keep enrolling which has been
the case for miami against
milwaukee and boston uh for for denver i
mean it's just
it's pretty remarkable it's ridiculous
that they have that capacity
to keep pushing back but yeah if you had
to go on the road to the staples center
for all these games by the way
uh it'd be hell to pay you you can't
even hear yourself think
and i will say hero would have been all
right that would have been a miami home
game
last night so he would have people been
carrying him in the street
if this was regular life i thought about
that damn like
think about the folks in la and denver
boston and miami whoever ends up
advancing in those areas
just howl that kind of i'll come out of
the arena at 1am after doing post game
and crickets like just just nothing in a
place like miami where
uh you can get down
just remember he's not even available
here he's not a sub he's a hero
oh my goodness just remember that just
better than grinder
oh yeah grinder yeah you can you can uh
work that in
also tyler the hero i think his middle
name should be changed to the
you okay with that we'll reach out to
moms okay yeah
bombing them are you going are you going
back to bed
not at all dawg i'll tell you where i'm
going i'm going into the postseason
hello you're sensitive everywhere i turn
i'm winning damn
your cincinnati reds oh my and your cy
young winner trevor bauer
come on he comes off that thing i just i
don't know how i could handle that if i
was a major league hitter
just the guttural screaming the stare
downs
but in the end you can hit it right i
mean you don't get you don't have to
deal with any of that
if you put your bat on the ball but boy
when he comes off snapping out of her i
can't handle it i call my brother
we curse on the phone pretty ridiculous
thanks for getting up
i know you got to bed late last night
but uh thanks for joining us to talk
about my heat
true love brother and welcome to the
nation i you need a flag back there
we'll get you a heat nation flag if you
don't mind flying it
yeah bring it yeah send it up see if no
doubt
ask riles if he'll sign it for me miami
heat partner fedex will take care of
that for you
thank you jay that's a jason jackson jr
iii
joining us on the program
that dude is funny what a knucklehead